we will lay down our souls and bodies
for our freedom
the words of the ukrainian national
anthem weigh much heavier now
no one expected to find themselves here
in an undisclosed location on the
outskirts of the city of odessa
i will always treat the gun as if it
were loaded
they are taught the basics of how to use
a weapon
this course takes place every day there
are no days off we really don't know how
much time we have before a russian
attack on odessa so we are trying to use
all time that we have to do as much as
possible for our people we don't teach
military tactics just how to operate a
gun and how to do that safely
these people have never held a weapon
before they're not going to be joining
the territorial army or civil defense
forces as they're known but they want to
know how to be able to operate a weapon
to be able to protect their homes to
protect their city if it gets to that
point
for many here it's not something that
comes naturally i never before have
weapons
and
now i'm totally not in doubt that i have
to protect my house
oleg's wife and daughter are in romania
now i cannot explain for my daughter
six years old that she is crying and
asking
why we cannot stay together why we
cannot stay in our home
and it's really hard
really hard
but what to do what to do
the city's been shelled anti-aircraft
defenses can be heard firing every day
most people here believe it's simply a
matter of time before russia turns its
full attention to ukraine's largest
seaport
olga is a lawyer and this is all new for
her too have you ever used a weapon
before never
never
usually i was afraid of a weapon do you
ever imagine that you this would be
happening never no no no no i have a
very
civil uh
hobby i don't stand go
yes i i don't wish
to to fight or something else no no it's
not for me i'm just a woman
but now every person in ukraine a woman
a man and doesn't matter we are fight we
need to fight
despite fear and anxiety here
there is strength from all being united
we're told
standing together in these unprecedented
and extraordinary times
[Applause]
stephanie decker al-jazeera in odessa
southwestern ukraine